how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some
extremely exciting marvel cinematic
universe news
and this is coming straight from disney
plus so it is 100
official during this pandemic things
have been a little bit crazy
specifically for marvel studios they've
had to shut down filming for most of
their projects that were in the works
including the falcon and the winter
soldier and
wanda vision they've pushed the release
date for black widow back and up until
this point nobody really knows when the
falcon and the winter soldier
and the one division series are going to
be released that is
until now today disney plus did a press
release
and in this press release they stated
that the wanda vision series that is
going to be taking place
in the mcu is still scheduled to arrive
in 2020
so it is official we are still going to
be getting the one division series this
year
this is great news and this was kind of
expected as it had a december release
date and most of the filming had already
been completed however we thought that
disney and marvel studios would want to
have the falcon and the winter soldier
out first before the release of the one
division series to keep the continuity
because as everybody knows
all of the mcu films are connected but
unfortunately nothing was mentioned
about the falcon in the winter soldier
only the confirmation that the one
division series is coming this year
now that doesn't mean that the falcon
and the winter soldier won't come this
year but it simply means that they're
still in the process of filming and
editing
maybe if they get it done in time it'll
come this year but we can expect one
division for sure
100 so it's about time we got some good
news from marvel studios in 2020
the wan division series will most likely
release in december which would be a
great way to end this year of 2020.
so incredible news let me know how
excited you are that we are still
getting the one division series in 2020
in the comments down below and also
don't forget to subscribe to enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
thanos funko pop and so you can stay up
to date on all the latest mcu news for
other giveaways and live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof